Israeli defense minister yuav Galant
says Israel is very close to achieving
its goals in Northern Gaza he says the
war is difficult but claimed Hamas
Fighters are surrendering to Israeli
forces we are very close to declaring
victory in Gaza City and will continue
our operations elsewhere all those
people whom we are fighting are facing
one fate they will be dismantled this is
also what is happening in K Yunis and I
would like to call upon them I would
like to call upon these terrorists and
their commanders to surrender I tell
them now surrender to save your lives if
not your fate will be
death meanwhile Israel's prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu has reportedly been
discussing plans for what happens next
after the war on Gaza is over some
Israeli media have published what they
say are leaks of netanyahu's
conversations with the knesset Foreign
Affairs and defense defense committee
Imran Khan has more now from Tel Aviv
well there's really two key things that
he said according to these leaks the
first one uh is about the Palestinian
Authority he said uh that the difference
between the Palestinian Authority and
Hamas is Hamas wanted to uh destroy
Israel immediately and uh that the
Palestinian Authority want to do it in
stages now this is going to come as a
big surprise of the Americans who want a
revitalized Palestinian Authority in
charge the day after uh the shooting
stops or at least during the process of
when the war ends in Gaza but he also
was talking about the day after he said
the strip will be under Israeli military
control after the war a civilian
administrator will operate in Gaza and
the strip will be re rehabilitated under
the leadership of the Gulf States by
rehabilitated he means rebuilding now
there is precedent for all of this uh
every time there's a war in Gaza it's
Kata uh that generally spends Millions
if not billions of dollars rebuilding
but I've spoken to the caty Ministry of
Foreign Affairs and they've said they
haven't had any discussions about
rebuilding Gaza they are focused on
getting a ceasefire and getting the
Israeli captives out and an exchange for
Palestinian prisoners so they're not
even talking about this all of these
comments suggest that Netanyahu is
trying to sell the fact that he's in
control internally the fact that he
hasn't actually come out and said any of
these comments publicly suggest that and
this is what's going to be happening
he's got a tough fight on his hands and
he needs to sell it internally but
before even remotely trying to go to the
Israeli
public we're joined Now by Maan Bashar
Al jaz's senior political analyst here
in the studio with us Mar what do you
make of these leaked remarks from
Benjamin
Netanyahu well clearly the um the
israelies are in a bit of a bind now and
there's a bit of disagreement among them
but they're also at the same time
reaching to what they call an inflection
point in
Gaza so there's a bit of disagreement
within the war cabinet there's a bit of
a disagreement about the war objectives
there's a bit of a disagreement about to
whether to
prioritize the captives or the defeating
of Hamas which means either to continue
with the war Non-Stop and even intensify
it or to find another diplomatic way in
order to try and free more
captives uh and there is the the images
that are coming out of Gaza the videos
are not very helpful to the Netanyahu
government uh if you watch some of those
videos that been diffused by uh the
Hamas military
arm uh certainly Israel is getting a
beating nowadays um even before more
than before and if you add to that the
the numbers that been declared by the
Israeli hospitals and how different they
are from the numbers declared by the
Israeli Army all of that really uh
starts to
shed the light on on a on a government
in crisis it's not very popular Nan per
se you know he he doesn't have the trust
of something like 96% of the Israeli
public that don't trust him that they
wouldn't take his word uh for fact given
what you say then does Israel feel that
politically its window for the continued
bombardment is essentially closing the
window is closing although there don't
admit it but uh if you listen to the
discussions with within the sort of
former military generals and the
Strategic analyst and so on so forth
they they understand that there is some
real American pressure some near
International pressure there's also the
economic pressure right Israel is losing
something like a quarter of a billion
dollar a year a day which means it's
going to really add up to a lot after
100 days of War that's why the window is
closed cling on this type of War but
that doesn't mean Israel would not
continue in a different kind of war
after say the end of this year meaning
they're going to something like I don't
know maybe you could call it a word of
attrition against Hamas but clearly
because the window of opportunity is
closing and because Israel is getting
AIT a bit of a beating to its soldiers
and tanks and so on so forth It's
intensifying it is bombardment against
the civilian population and that's why
we're probably going to see more and
more of these high figures of Civilian
deaths including journalists and doctors
and and uh and uh teachers and so on so
is there as much so-called progress
being made by the Israeli military as
they would like the world to believe in
terms of its fight against Hamas look
there's no do there's no doubt about the
disit of forces
here um there is sort of a a battle of
narrative
a b battle of images going on but there
is no doubt about who has more Firepower
right so Israel has more Firepower but
there is an international pressure about
the genocide that unraveling in Gaza
there's International there's more
American pressure there's more Arab
pressure so Israel in terms of its
Firepower surely it it will continue to
destroy more and more as time goes by
more tunnels more Hamas Fighters more
civilian population more civilian
infrastructure but how much time right
So eventually Israel could flatten Gaza
but for the time
being while it can win the war
militarily it's slowly but surely losing
the war strategically and otherwise it
says that it is a war between the the
the the forces of light against the
forces of Darkness but more and more
everyone understand this is about
genocidal and occupiers against occupied
and on a wider strategy we've heard
about Lebanon Israel border clashes is
that a matter of containment at the
moment or could a miscalculation change
that for the time being there's no doubt
that it is one of containment however
there could be miscalculation and it
could widen interestingly when the
Israelis now talk about the they after
Gaza you would think as the Americans
think let's discuss the two-state
solution but when the Israelis discuss
that they after Gaza they are thinking
Lebanon now that doesn't mean War it
could also mean a diplomatic solution
that somehow pushes Hezbollah north of
the Lan River as the is as the Israelis
demand of course that will require other
demands by Hezbollah but it could also
involve a preemptive strike on Hezbollah
and if that happens then we are
definitely talking about a wider war
with with Incredible consequences for
the region we'll leave it there Maran
Bashar our senior political analyst
thank
you